people love their king
they know I saved the city they know I
won the war
Wars not one it's tempting to see your
enemies as evil but there's good and
evil on both sides in every war ever
fought
they have a choice they can live in my
new world or they can die in their old
one things are a bit tense right now and
don't think I'm talking my way out of
this one
Marlon's preach the ball to roll over
everything and everyone
given the opportunity what do we do to
those who've hurt the ones we love
I want to know which side you're on
tell your father I'm here and tell him
the Lannisters are the only ones who pay
their debt you fight over him like
beasts until you tear and cut I will
burn our house to the ground before I
let that happen
tonight we fight
there's only one hell the one we live in
now
if you want justice you've come to the
wrong place